apple m'envoyer à quelques jours les
airs potts pro que j'ai pu tester dont
j'ai pu profiter que j'ai pu écouter
pendant un bon petit moment et
aujourd'hui c'est le jour du verdict
pour vous dire ce que je pense de ces
nouveaux airs pop pro d'apple de ses
nouveaux produits parce qu'on
connaissait les reposes jusque là je
pense que nous apprend absolument rien
il ya les airs potts 2 sorti l'année
dernière et là on arrive sur un nouveau
modèle soro diop ce sont des nouveaux
airs pop c'est une nouvelle proposition
de valeur karpov pro que je trouve très
intéressant je vais vous expliquer
pourquoi ya des choses que j'aime
beaucoup
avec sa rolls pro et des choses qui sont
assez un peu dommage la copie est
presque parfaite je vous explique tout
[Musique]
je vous rappelle que durant tout le 20
novembre c'est vous qui votez pour élire
les smartphones de l'année dans
différentes catégories les résultats
seront donnés lors de la grande soirée
de la téléphonie mobile
début décembre je ferai un compte-rendu
en vidéo et c'est vous qui allez voter
c'est vous qui votez et qui donnait vos
oas directement aux constructeurs pour
ce faire vous avez le lien en bas d'un
description il ya aussi une vidéo en
ligne pour expliquer comment ça marche
vous pouvez y aller pouvaient voter
comme ça vous aurez tout et c'est vous
qui décidez c'est vous qui avez le
contrôle c'est vous qui avez la main et
c'est vous qui allez choisir qui seront
les gagnants des différentes catégories
parlons maintenant de serre cosprons
l'airpod procès est une tout nouvelle
proposition de valeur par rapport aux
herbes folles ce qu'on avait avant déjà
la boîte change vous le voyez ne
serait-ce que le format est relativement
différent
l'airpod vous les ouvriers comme ça vous
aviez vos deux tiers pose ici mais un
peu de ce procès différents la forme et
pas la même la boîte est plus grande ce
qui donne à tous ne me dérange pas parce
que ça tient toujours très très très
très bien dans une poche
ils sont surtout beaucoup plus petit que
l'airpod plus standard hier paul
classique c'est pas du tout la même
fabrication parce qu'en fait vous n'avez
pas du tout le même produit chaque
arpels pèse 5,4 g vous avez de la
réduction de bruit active qui est
complètement désactivable vous avez vos
petits en bout là que vous pouvez venir
enlever on est comme d'habitude chez
apple sur un format propriétaire
vous avez trois tailles petit moyen ou
grand un des premiers points très
positifs avec sharepoint
c'est la tenue dans l'oreille vous
prenez vous appuyez vous avez déjà une
réduction passive ça vient là déjà
brillé je le mets il s'est activée le
fait d'avoir positionner comme ça ils
avaient envie hop voilà je l'aimé comme
ça j'ai déjà une réduction facile et l'a
déjà j'ai la réduction de bruit ça
vienne couper alors je m'entends tu
entends ma voix dans ma tête pendant un
peu moins bien ça vient vraiment me
couper de l'extérieur ça s'est vraiment
bien ses premiers points sert qu'à la
différence les premières fautes ce que
vous aviez pour vous veniez vous preniez
votre pote et vous le posez ici
directement sur le conduit c'est à dire
que l'airpod il venait en fait je peux
tout le travail il venait et il se poser
comme ça ici les nouveaux airs potes et
bien c'est tout tout tout un nouveau
système qui vient complètement bouché
votre oreille ça vient obstruer la
grosse différence que vous avez aussi
c'est que là la tige est un peu plus
courte
là vous avez une tige qui est beaucoup
plus longs ont un design qui est quand
même relativement différent mais surtout
un des points qui est très important
avec ce genre de chose s'il voulait que
ces petits écouteurs c'est que vous ayez
un confort que vous les ayez comme ça
vos oreilles et qui vous gêne pas en
plus d'une excellente tenue ou et bouge
la tête d'où les côtés vous pouvez pas
voter pour y courir lorsque vous voulez
il ne bouge
so lu ment pas une très belle
fabrication au niveau dire tu as pro et
ça c'est vraiment super cool sur cère
post pro vous avez des micros à
l'extérieur qui vont venir détecter le
bruit ambiant qui vont générer un bruit
équivalente qui vont créer un système de
hors phase c'est-à-dire qu'ils vont
prendre le sont ils vont venir
l'injecter à l'intérieur ça va créer un
orfèvre quand on prend le même sens et
qu'on le met hors frasques ce qui se
passe est bien le son ça nulle leçon
disparaît et c'est comme ça que se crée
la réduction de bruit active
on a donc une réduction de bruit qui est
vraiment hypra efficace qui va vraiment
faire un super bon boulot lors ya
plusieurs votes qui existent vous avez
le mode avec la réduction d'objectif qui
va vraiment venir à nu les leçons
extérieur ça c'est bien et vous avez
notre mode qui s'appelle le mode
transparence qui est lui par contre
devenir amplifier le son extérieur pour
vous entendiez à la fois votre musique
et que vous entendiez ce qui se passe à
l'extérieur
l'idée c'est tout simplement que déjà
lorsque vous l'avez comme ça c'est une
réduction de bruit active à la
différence des repos avant qu'ils
étaient posées vous entendez ce qui se
passait à l'extérieur
là vous n'entendez plus que très peu qui
se passe à l'extérieur ça va devenir
amplifier le son extérieur vous
permettre de l'entendre de façon très
naturelle elle rendu vraiment
intéressant parce que on a vraiment
station naturel on n'a pas l'impression
d'avoir un truc qui est sûr amplifié
avec un soin plus robotique c'est très
naturel c'est très doux ça fonctionne
très très bien ça vous permet de
discuter sans aucun problème c'est au
comedd doit rendre compte de votre
environnement s'est par exemple d'aller
faire du rni que vous courrez peut
l'utiliser pour plusieurs et ont déjà
parce que j'ai une très très bonne tenue
en plus il est certifié pour résister à
l'eau et à la sueur donc si vous courez
hélas la mesure vous courrez vous
transpirez même s'il pleut il ya aucun
problème d'identification ipx4 vous
permet au courant d'entendre s'il ya des
véhicules autour de vous si une voiture
si vous allez courir en ville dont vous
sentez vraiment en sécurité si par
exemple vous êtes dans un aéroport et
qu'à un moment vous voulez entendre les
annonces profitent également de votre
musique
eh bien vous activez le mode
transparence vous entendez les annonces
pour venir changer la réduction de bruit
c'est très très simple sur vos écouteurs
vous avez ici un petit bouton lorsque
vous appuyez une fois sa dette rappelait
ou pause quand on vous appelle permettra
de décrocher ou de raccrocher vous
appuyez deux fois morceau suivant trois
fois morceaux précédents lorsque vous
les switch et de réduction de bruit
active à notre transparence et bien vous
laisser appuyer dessus pendant deux
secondes devant tant d un petit bip dans
vos oreilles
ça change de mode vous switchez comme ça
un appui long vous switcher de l'un à
l'autre c'est extrêmement facile à
utiliser j'utilise déjà un casque à
réduction de bruit la réduction druzes
utilise assez souvent lorsque j'écoute
de la musique mais pas tout le temps
j'utilise souvent je suis notamment dans
un train ou dans un avion pour me couper
un peu du
oui environnement écran vivement lorsque
vous prenez l'avion pendant des heures
eh bien ça nous permet de voyager dans
des conditions qui sont vraiment
différentes vous êtes quand même un peu
plus reposé et c'est vraiment bien aussi
pour le faire avec ses airs potts pro
vous activez votre réduction de bruit
vous mettez pas de musique croyez moi ça
vaut coupe ça vous fait un bien fou ça
c'est top
alors maintenant quand les types de la
qualité parce que ça reste quand même le
point essentiel d r paul cros on va
acheter des repose à 279 euros mais
derrière on veut de la qualité on veut
ce qui fait mieux déjà avec les
premières générations der pol vous avez
homme je sais même pas est-ce que les
autres ils sont rangés là vous avez déjà
une excellente qualité
ils étaient connus et reconnus pour leur
qualité audio on va garder exactement la
même qualité avec les reposes pro c'est
tout l'adn d'apple c'est de proposer un
format qui est très fin qui est très
petit avec une excellente qualité
quelque chose qui marche vachement bien
que s'adapte bien c'est toute l'idée en
tout cas derrière ces lagos pro vous
avez ce qu'apple appelle l'égalisation
adaptative alors l'égalisation
d'atlantis à permettre de moduler la
qualité du son en fonction de votre
oreille ça va venir calibrer la musique
différemment en fonction de la forme de
votre oreille il faut savoir qu'à
l'intérieur de vos l'ère post pro vous
avez un petit micro le petit micro
qu'est ce qu'il va faire il va venir
capter le son dans votre oreille et en
fonction de ce que le haut parleur va y
mettre et de ce que le micro va capter
il va adapter automatiquement la qualité
du son pour ceux toujours adaptés à
votre oreille on a donc un son qui
s'adapte parfaitement bien qui est
personnalisé la qualité va donc être
maximale selon chaque utilisateur en
termes de performances on à la puce a5
qui fonctionne parfaitement bien qui
vous restitue du sont d'excellente
qualité
on avait déjà son kit est très très très
bon en qu'après ma génération airports
est là avec cette génération pro apple
ne déroge pas à la règle
on l'a donc des graves d'excellente
qualité des graves bien on qui ronronne
bien on arrive vers des médiums qui sont
assez précis très juste et même
lorsqu'on va monter en fréquence on se
retrouve sur des aigus qu'on arrivait
sur des cymbales sont des instruments
qui ont des sons très aigus et bien il
ya de la précision n'inspecte qui est
cohérent on va pas se retrouver avec
comme sur les casques beats avec des
graves qui vont trop ronronner qui vont
être omniprésent dont c'est bien c'est
linéaire c'est clean c'est classe ça
marche bien d'ailleurs c'est toujours ça
qui m'a bluffé avec ses airs pose déjà
pu en fait plus avec les retours ce
procès dire qu'avec des petits écouteurs
comme ça vous arrivez à restituer un
spectre très large et d'excellente
qualité donc pour moi le résultat audio
est toujours à la hauteur chez apple pas
nous allons sur l'autonomie qui va
jusqu'à plus de 24
avec le boîtier de recharge par contre
sur chaque airpod pro apple nous annonce
4,5 heures d'autonomie lorsque vous avez
aux épaules comme ça 4h30 pas
nécessairement mais au delà de quatre
heures ça c'est sûr et bien voorpost va
falloir vous les recharges y est pour
les recharger il ya rien de bien
révolutionnaire vous les prenez ob vous
les mettez chacun dans votre petite
boîte indépendamment un peu nous annonce
qu'en cinq minutes de chat vous avez
déjà récupéré une heure d'écouté
à noter que vous avez la possibilité de
le recharger lui directement en
induction vous pouvez le poser ça marche
bien
ou alors directement ici avec un câble
lightning bien évidemment vous retrouvez
syrie directement vous avez affaire elle
syrie et là vous allez pouvoir commander
ce que vous voulez à la voix directement
avec votre iphone ça c'est pratique mais
vous pouvez également l'utiliser sur
android vous les allumés vous êtes dans
les paramètres bluetooth de votre
smartphone et la pesée pour les
appareils et comme n'importe quels
écouteurs directement sur android y'a un
truc qui est vraiment bien lorsque vous
utilisez avec un iphone avec ios c'est
vous pouvez partager l'audio pour
écouter avec 2 et repose avec des herbes
folles
imaginez par exemple c'est pas moi vous
êtes en couple vous fait un petit film
et voulait pas faire de bruit vous
voulez pas être embêté et bien il y en a
qui va prendre ses airs pop un peu
classique vous tirer sa chifoumi comme
vous voulez la deuxième personne aura
les erp aux pros que vous écouterez
exactement la même chose le même film
bien évidemment dr potts qui sont
bluetooth 5.0 alors moi je les trouve
presque parfait ya un excellent travail
qui a été fait par apple alors comme
d'habitude chez apple on est sur des
produits qui sont quand même
relativement cher 279 euros pour dire
aux profs c'est un budget c'est un beau
budget et ça le place dans le haut du
panier le très haut du panier pour ce
genre de petites bêtes par contre
derrière d une qualité audio qui est
vraiment très très bien maîtrisé la
réduction de bruit est bonne ce n'est
peut-être pas la meilleure du marché sur
cette typologie de produits en tout cas
elle est vraiment excellente comme tous
les repositionner très facilement avec
votre iphone on a donc un produit qui
est vraiment très très bien
en tout mon point quasiment parfait
quasiment parce qu'à trois points qui me
chiffonne le premier c'est que bien vous
ayez une égalisation adaptative et bien
vous n'avez pas pouvoir vous avoir accès
à une application pour venir égaliser
pour mettre les paramètres audio vous
voulez d'envoyer repose on va pas
écouter différents styles musicaux de la
même manière par exemple de la musique
classique du jazz du métal du hip hop et
bien des fois on a envie de pouvoir
jouer un petit peu ce qu'on sait c'est
que l'isr soit monte un peu les bases
soit creusé un peu les médiums soit mon
appel d'offres il ya pas mal de
possibilités et là c'est strictement
impossible vous écouter la musique telle
qu'elle est et vous ne pouvez pas les
changer ça c'est un peu le truc qui
m'embête surtout quand on sait qu'un
produit équivalent chez sony
on peut le faire il ya une application
dédiée voilà ça ça aurait été
intéressant
le deuxième point c'est que vous ne
pouvez pas changer le volume 2 go et
repose directement sur votre pote ça
aurait été intéressant qui est en tout
cas une fonction dédiée sur le bouton ou
alors je sais pas un petit mode soit
pour quelque chose qui vous permettent
de monter le volume de baisser le volume
là vous pouvez pas le faire lorsque vous
tournez bien évidemment sur ios vous
pouvez appeler série a et série monte le
volume et eseries baisse le volume mais
quand vous êtes dans un avion va c'est
pas très pratique lorsque vous écoutez
de la musique vous êtes connecté en
bluetooth voulait pas forcément pouvoir
chaque fois sortir vos smartphones le
bcs série vous allez pas l'appeler ça
aurait été vraiment bien qu'une petite
commande ça m'aurait semble en tout cas
être dans le bon sens et le troisième
point c'est la question de l'autonomie
alors je comprends on est vraiment sur
les toutes petites choses avec ses ipod
ce procès vraiment pas très très grande
pour loger une grosse batterie c'est un
petit peu compliqué mais lorsque vous
prenez l'avion lorsque moi par exemple
je me prends un vol j'ai six heures
d'avion et bien ce moment là j'aime bien
les utiliser pendant tout le vol même si
je vous dis c'est d'utiliser fois
uniquement pour avoir une réduction de
bruit active et pour ne pas écouter de
musique sauf que là avec uniquement
quatre heures d'autonomie et bien c'est
pas très pratique il ya quand même en
point qui est extrêmement positif c'est
que vous prenez up votre petit boîtier
vous les mettez dedans voulait poser
cinq minutes et vous êtes reparti pour
la durée de votre vol donc ça c'est bien
mais voilà ça c'est un peu un des points
négatifs j'aurais aimé qu'il y ait une
plus grosse autonomie là dedans bon
voilà on peut pas tout avoir
alors l'ère post prod ne sont peut-être
pas parfait on peut probablement les
améliorer peut-être sur une v2 peut-être
allez savoir
en tout cas même si ce n'est pas parfait
ils sont vraiment excellents et de très
loin ce n'est pas ce que vous en pensez
en bas en commentaire comment vous le
trouvez cirque aux pros est ce que vous
aviez déjà vous dr potes et est ce que
ces erp aux pros peuvent vous faire de
l'oeil alors effectivement on est chez
apple chez apple c'est toujours cher à
côté de ça c'est bourré de technologie
il ya vraiment beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de techno intérieur il
ya un très gros travail de r&d
c'est les fruits qui sont vraiment
nouveau dans la gamme qui ont
effectivement la dénomination airs potes
mais on est sur autre chose sur tout
autre chose et moi je trouve
intéressante et au ce que vous en pensez
en bas en commentaire n'oubliez pas
d'aller voter pour choisir le smartphone
de 2019
et quand un match de deux rendez-vous
dès demain vous embrasse ciao